you know loading position types and okay
thank you and thank you organizers for
the invitation this has been a really
great week with a great collection of
people heard about some fascinating
things I'm sure I wouldn't have
encountered otherwise so this talks
learn to combine a number of threads
which are all more or less related to
the themes of the of the workshop so
this is joint work with on our DARPA
it's one of my postdocs it's also work
in progress so it's not complete but
it's progressing quite well so I think I
can give you a good impression of where
it's all going
so the first thread of background to
introduce is the curry Howard
correspondence also known as the the
propositions as types paradigm so this
is a cornerstone of theoretical computer
science and semantics and really they're
the foundation of functional programming
languages and it's this idea of setting
up a correspondence between programming
language types and logical propositions
this extends to correspondence between
programs and and proofs of the
propositions and then dynamics is
introduced by the idea that evaluation
of a program corresponds to proof
normalization or or cut elimination so
specifically in the in the core case
what this means is that a function type
RR be the type of functions from from
data a today to be is identified with
the proof of a implies B so
computationally we think of the function
as a construction of a proof of B from a
given proof of a and the idea of this
evaluation is as proof normalization
correspondence is that on the one hand
if you think about applying a function
to a parameter in lambda calculus the
parameter gets substituted into the body
of the function at all the places where
it's used and correspondingly and the
idea of cut elimination is that logical
cut is matching up a implies B with with
a and you can think of it as as
applying a lever and cut elimination
means that the dilemma is inlined in the
proof that's using it everywhere it
occurs and if you're not familiar with
this area and want to learn more about
it there's a very nice article by I feel
what lo which was published in
communications of the ACM just a year
ago so I recommend that for the
background reading this is all very nice
for the functional programming for
sequential computation and the question
that's been around for quite a long time
is is what should the corresponding
setup look like for concurrent
programming and way back in 1987 when
Johnny of Gerar introduced linear logic
the idea appeared and was explicitly
suggested by G Robert that linear logic
and in particular classical linear logic
should have something to do with with
concurrent computation of perhaps might
form a basis for a nice curry Howard
correspondence and in the in the years
following the introduction of of linear
logic there was some work looking at
this kind of connection looking at PI
calculus looking at a classical linear
logic proofs and and certain
correspondences were were obtained but I
think it's fair to say that the results
that were obtained didn't really catch
on as the answer to the question of what
is the curry Howard correspondence for
currency and didn't become the
foundation for concurrent programming
languages in the way that functional
languages have their foundation in this
logical correspondence and then work
work in this direction sort of rather
died down for a number of years
meanwhile the second thread of
background I need to introduces the
session types which we've already heard
about extensively from mobile Co at the
beginning of the week so session types
were introduced by Kohei condor around
1993 and then further developed with a
number of of co-workers and the idea of
session types is to use type theoretic
techniques to describe the structure of
communication in concurrent systems and
I'm vastly simplifying here and only
showing you there
most basic cases of a of an input so the
question mark means input input a then B
this is a protocol which says first
receive a message of type a and then
continue to behave as protocol B and
dually so the complementary description
of the what's happening at the other end
of this communication channel send a
message of type A and then behave as B
and if these were to actually match up
the B here would have to be do alized in
this way which I I didn't show now there
are other possibilities so you can also
represent branching so protocols that
have choices at certain points and can
go in different directions but I only
need this much to explain now Nobuko was
talking about multi-party session types
which is how you describe collective
communications among a number of
concurrent agents but here I'm just
talking about what are known as binary
session types we're talking about the
the type of a protocol on on one channel
connecting to there's been a lot of work
in session types over the last 20 years
and more and it's really developed into
a large and active research area and you
know most of the programming language
and theory conferences seem to have a
couple of papers on session types these
days and then in in 2010 Louis Kairos
and Frank Fanning published a paper in
which they developed a Curie Howard
style correspondence between in the form
of linear logic this was dual
intuitionistic linear logic and session
types for the PI calculus and this was
really I mean when I read this paper
this this absolutely impressed me and
this really seems to have a good claim
to be curry Howard for the concurrency
and part of the reason for saying it has
a good claim to be the answer to curry
Howard for concurrency is that just like
the original functional curry how a
correspondence it's proved possible to
develop and and extend it with a lot of
extra features so quantifiers dependent
types logical modalities other logical
features which find corresponding
analogs on the on
professional side and what happens in
this setup is that whereas in the the
original Kurihara correspondence proof
normalization or cut elimination
corresponds to their functional
computation and an application in lambda
calculus here cut elimination
corresponds to communication sending and
receiving a message matching up and
there's been a very productive series of
work by courage and fanning and they're
their co-workers over the last few years
really pushing this idea a long way so
just to give you a little flavor of of
how that works that the thing that was
really amazing about this is that they
they identified the connectives of
linear logic with with the type
constructors obsession session types in
in really quite a surprising way
so tensor corresponds to two output so
the type a tensor b means that is the
type of a communication channel on which
you first send a message of type a and
then continue to behave according to
protocol b and par which is the DeMorgan
dual of tensor and classical linear
logic corresponds to two input so this
is input a message of type a and then
continue to behave as a protocol b and
the remarkable thing and that you can
see just very formally in these in these
rules is that the the channel so so here
you know you've got propositions
annotated with with proof term to this
bit on the left is the process that
there receives on channel x what it
receives is is called y which is then
bound and then you continue to use the
same channel right so you've got X here
and and X here so that the channel is
threaded through the rule and the same
thing happens down here you you send
value Y on X and then continue to to use
out so the combination of these two
ideas that that that the tensor is
output and par is input and that the way
you do the the term assignment improves
is by is by threading that
through it made the whole thing work and
these were really quite quite surprising
ideas okay and this diagram is a not
very beautiful attempt to illustrate
what happens in in cut elimination in
this setup so this this is supposed to
be the process that's that's inputting
and this is the process that's ending
and this line here is that the
connection between them so the
communication channel that that connects
them and the reason why this this line
extends up here and extends up here just
corresponds exactly to this this
threading of the channel and this little
bit of line is meant to be the message
this is meant to be the message and
you'll notice that another feature of
this ruler output is that you've got two
processes in parallel here so the
vertical bar is is parallel the the
message that's being sent is is created
by a separate parallel component than
the one that's that's running the rest
of the protocol and that's why there are
these two two boxes here and what
happens in a in a communication step is
that the the message gets matched up
this is where the message is consumed
and this is where it's produced and then
the continuation of the protocol gets
gets matched up like that so what
happens here is that a cut on a more
complex formula is replaced by two cuts
on simpler formula and then inductively
this enables cuts to eventually be
eliminated
okay so third thread to introduce is the
idea of analyzing deadlocks in
communicating systems so deadlock is
what happens when a concurrent system is
unable to make progress because
communications are blocking each other
so here are two archetypal examples of
of deadlock and and non deadlock so
what's happening here is that we've got
two components in parallel they're both
using channel a and channel B I don't
care about the messages just the
channels and here we've got input on a
followed by output on B in parallel with
output on a followed by input on B and
this is fine because the the a use can
match up and then the B's can match up
but underneath we've got something where
the output an input has been exchanged
here so both processes are waiting for
an input which is never going to happen
because the corresponding output is
behind the other input so this is a
deadlock and this is this is okay so the
deadlock in this sense is something that
can happen when you've got two processes
sharing more than one channel and it
comes from a cyclic dependency and one
feature of this some carry howard set up
with session types and linear logic is
that the type system as well as
guaranteeing correct communication in
the sense that messages are always of
the expected type it also guarantees
deadlock freedom by imposing a very
strong condition that you could only
connect processes maya a single channel
and that stops this situation arising so
this is the cut rule in classical linear
logic which enables you to to plug two
processes together
jewelle types so you can't make any
cyclic connections they can't do
anything like this which excludes this
deadlock situation and this situation
which is actually not a deadlock okay so
in a sense the the deadlock freedom
mechanism in the courage and failing
system is is too strong and in fact if
you just flip back here it's important
that you've got these two separate
components within the output side
because that's what preserves this
invariant that the connection structure
of the processes is is always a tree
okay so two
analyzed deadlocks in her in a more
sophisticated way naked copy yeah she in
a whole series of work going back to
1997 has developed type systems based on
the idea that there must be a consistent
order on communication channels and the
way they're used all the way through a
system and so if we look back at these
two examples the reason why this one is
a deadlock is that you've got
inconsistent orderings on the channels
but this one's okay because you can
consistently say that a happens before B
so it's possible to set up a type system
for the PI calculus based on this idea
which guarantees deadlock freedom by
type checking but is more expressive
than the carriage and feminine system
procession types and this idea has also
been formulated for a session type
system by I look at Padovani but without
this without this logical correspondence
like these these systems have been
developed just as a type system for the
PI calculus without any logical so to
get to the point of what we have been
working on it is to combine all these
ideas into a more expressive deadlock
free type system with a logical
correspondence thus extending the the
Curie Howard set up for session times
and so what you really want to be able
to do in order to form this kind of
configuration is to generalize the other
cut rule that lets you plug on a single
channel to this rule which is called
multi cut that lets you plug as many
channels together as you want as long as
their types match up duly but actually
you can you can shuffle things around in
terms of which rules you have and
instead of introducing the multi cut
rule we use mix and cycle so mix just
lets you put things side by side without
connection and cycle lets you form a an
internal connection and between them
these rules in
so the idea of bringing in the the copy
a key style type system is that every
every type that is every proposition
gets tagged with a priority which is a
natural number and then all the proof
rules as well as the usual hypotheses
are augmented with conditions on on
priorities and the most important thing
to look at is in the rules for input and
output where the the priority that gets
associated with the with the input or or
output connective has to be smaller that
is higher priority than all the types
that the process is using afterwards
it's a guarding corresponds to having a
higher priority or higher priority means
smaller in this in this partial order so
something else that happens when you
introduce the cycle rule into the logic
is that the distinction between tensor
and power disappears and that's why we
end up with the same form of typing rule
for both input and output so we no
longer need the fact that in the output
rule the message and the continuation
are handled by separate parallel
processes because we've now got a more
powerful way of guaranteeing deadlock
freedom but we choose not to just
identify tension and power they're going
to become isomorphic rather than
identical okay and in the cycle rule in
order to form this this connection
between two ports as well as their types
being dual they have to have the same
priority which means eventually those
two communication operations will be
ready at the same time and that's what
bits make progress
okay so I'll skip this because I'm
running out of time that's just a
summary of the proof of of deadlock
freedom in the Kobayashi style type
systems and so what we expect to do is
first of all prove that our system
derives everything that the original
session type linear logic system can and
then to take the Kobayashi style
reasoning from the deadlock new type
systems and repackage it into a proof of
now cycle of innovation rather than
customization for classical linear logic
and potential applications would be
development of of more expressive type
systems for concurrent programming
languages based on this linear logic
correspondence so for example Frank
pfennig and his group have been working
on implementations of concurrent
programming languages with type systems
based on the correspondence and if we
used the style of type system we're
developing these languages would become
more more expressive okay so that's it
[Applause]
I'm a historical oh yes right well yes
that's yes that's true yes I should have
yes yes yes that's that's drive not work
who mentioned it
so in fact yes so in fact when people
talk about multi-cut they refer to that
paper and interestingly so in in some
sense that was going in the opposite
direction in that we were starting with
the setting where anything goes and then
refining the types to to prevent cyclic
connections and then here we're starting
with the setting where you can't have
psychic connections and we're refining
the types to allow them in in safe
situations but yeah well I think so and
in fact the none of as far as I know
none of this stream of work about curry
Howard and session types has explored to
the categorical by mention yet so
there's an opportunity there to always
emphasized that the when you wrote you
were mentioning his recent work yeah
yeah I mean it's all been brought into
the into the picture it's used too many
times
the eunuch acids used to only once and
the IPT not very dirty - it's a yoga but
section this city dependent one vineyard
some have used too many friends because
in 2003 it's that yeah you can prove the
empty sequence yeah I mean the thing is
in the setting you're more interested in
the proofs rather than what's proved but
yeah but yeah I mean yes you do end up
me and prove um please you couldn't yeah
so what so what I mean why are you so
interested in deadlock freedom I mean so
there are two aspects to it one is that
you don't want the you don't want the
wrong messages to be sent this is my
question
I mean why wouldn't you like what I
guess I'm asking is there research which
explores it rather than starting with
linear logic starting with a fact across
categories where you without having a
separable static priorities on channels
well as I was saying the the I mean the
categorical side of this line of work
hasn't been explored yet
but the no I mean that the you know the
motivation was that so in in the in the
multi-party session types work that no
Bakr was talking about you get deadlock
freedom because you start with this
global type which you project everything
from if you just work with binary
session types so you're just looking at
protocols and individual channels you
you don't get deadlock free them so the
fact that you get deadlock freedom from
this cars and pending work was seen as a
as a bonus because it's giving you a
stronger correctness property and so
then there's the observation that well
there's that you know there's an even
better system for deadlock freedom by
copy actually so can we combine that or
liveliness because although system
permanent because of course it's the
fitful optically means that some apart
so you can execute so it doesn't just
progress well the cars tanning system
doesn't have recursion so everything's
everything is terminating and it's a
question of whether it terminates
successfully or whether it gets stuck
along the way so
yes or what we're looking at is the the
the Kobayashi typing idea applied to the
cars and felling system without
recursion yeah I mean maybe it can be
extended later
[Applause]